the movie opens in the year 1898
featuring a prospector Daniel Plan view
he is currently mining a potentially
precious or vin from a pit mine hole
when he unearths silver he puts some
Dynamite to create a bigger hole after
carrying out an explosion Daniel
reenters the hole during which he
accidentally trips and falls causing him
to break his leg despite being in
excruciating pain he collects some
silver stones in his shirt and somehow
manages to climb out dragging his broken
leg behind he eventually takes takes the
silver sample to an aay office from
which he receives a silver and gold
certificate claim the scene then cuts to
1902 when Daniel discovers oil near Los
Angeles and establishes his own drilling
company in the midst of extracting oil
from underground an accident with the
Machinery results in the tragic demise
of one of his workers leaving his baby
boy orphaned as a result Daniel decides
to adopt the orphaned boy and names him
HW plan view over time the boy becomes
his nominal business partner allowing
Daniel to present himself as a family
man in front of potential investors and
gain their trust the duo travel from
town to town with a heartwarming speech
requesting the investors to choose them
when it comes to leasing their land for
drilling whenever someone asks him about
his wife Daniel simply replies that she
died in child birth in 1911 Daniel is
approached by Paul Sunday a young man
who reveals an oil deposit beneath his
family's property in little Boston
California hearing this Daniel tries to
get the details out of him but the
latter demands $500 in exchange for the
information upon fulfilling his demand
the young man shows them the exact
location of his family's Ranch in the
next scene Daniel and HW visit the area
pretending to be on a quail hunt oh kill
me a feel quals boy as they arrive at
the ranch they meet Paul's father Abel
who welcomes them in a warm manner
offering them some water and goat milk
while they set up their Camp they
approached by Paul's twin brother Eli a
local preacher who promises to bring
them dinner in a pretense of quail
hunting where are the quails boy the
Father and Son explore the area and soon
discover oil confirming Paul's claim
Daniel believes that this is a great
spot to build a pipeline take it to the
beach and strike a deal with Union oil
he also tells his son that owning this
place will cut off their railroads and
shipping costs ultimately allowing them
to make a lot of money later after
dinner Daniel has a private conversation
with Abel and Eli expressing his wish to
buy their land when Eli questions his
motive Daniel claims that he loves
hunting for quail and also that his son
needs fresh air is he is sick he then
offers them a minimal amount but Eli who
knows about oil as well as the land's
drilling potential demands
$10,000 for his church Daniel eventually
manages to settle on an agreement for
5,000 payable only after the well starts
producing and the fraking quails too the
very next day Daniel goes to see a real
estate agent agent to ask for
information about all the land owners
around the Sundays so that he can look
into buying them as well he also calls
his business partner asking him to bring
all of their employees to the area to
start the work immediately while Daniel
is busy in his new big project HW begins
to spend time with Abel's youngest
daughter Mary who is of his age during
this HW learns that her father beats her
if she doesn't pray and later shares
this news with Daniel eventually the
camp tents are set and the construction
of the drilling site slowly begins
Daniel acquires all the available land
in and around the Sunday property except
for one hold out that belongs to a guy
named William Bandy William wants to
talk to Daniel in person but the latter
thinks that it's all a ruse to get him
to offer him more money so he neglects
him for now one day Daniel gives a
speech to the locals about how oil
drilling will facilitate the development
of the entire area he also promises to
build schools Wells New Roads and
cultivation in in the area creating
employment opportunities for everyone
after days of construction the
preparation for drilling is almost
complete on the inauguration day Daniel
offers a few words with Mary and HW by
his side but he doesn't allow Eli to
carry out his quick blessing HW then
inaugurates the project by pulling the
lever and finally beginning the drilling
process in the aftermath Daniel arranges
A Feast for all the residents to
celebrate this occasion Abel is right in
front of Daniel when he talks to Mary he
promises the girl that her father will
not beat her anymore the same night a
misfortune occurs a huge Rod slips from
the worker's hands and hits another
employee placed inside the well causing
him to die on the spot when Daniel is
informed about this tragic incident he
scolds his workers for not adopting
precautionary measures he then gathers
the Dead Man's belongings in a chest and
prepares to dispose of his body the
following morning Daniel goes to see Eli
who is in the middle of a sermon that
appears quite dramatic get out demons
this scene made me hate Paul Doo after
the session Daniel asks him to recite
some prayer in honor of his dead
employee although Eli agrees he still
believes that it's dangerous for the
workers to work on an unblessed well
however Daniel refuses to allow his men
to attend church during their free time
as he believes that they must rest a few
days later another incident breaks out a
gas leak causes a huge explosion HW is
right there during the incident but
Daniel rushes to save him before the
sight catches fire he brings him to a
tent and asks if he's okay but the boy
is unable to hear anything turns out
that the sound of the Blast has deafened
the boy moreover the fire causes the
entire drilling infrastructure to
crumble down the next day the fire
persists So Daniel resorts to using
Dynamite to force the burning fuel and
oxygen away from the fuel source
ultimately extinguishing the fire that
night he sleeps cuddling with his son
who keeps on on letting out a humming
voice since he can't hear his own voice
in the later days HW starts to spend all
of his time in bed visibly depressed so
Daniel decides to find him a teacher
from the city to help him through his
disability one day Eli approaches Daniel
in front of his workers and demands the
money still owed to him Daniel who is
already frustrated by the ongoing
problems in his life slaps and
humiliates him he also yells at him for
not healing his son despite being a
preacher in a fit of rage he drags him
by his hair and drops him in a pool of
oil warning him against asking for the
money again later at the dinner table
Eli berates his father for trusting
Daniel referring to him as a foolish man
when the old man tries to reason Eli
attacks him throwing him off the table
some days later an unknown Man shows up
at Daniel's door claiming himself to be
Henry PL view his half brother Daniel is
initially hesitant to believe him but he
is convinced when Henry shows him proof
there sister's letter mentioning their
father's demise 3 months prior inviting
him inside the brothers engage in a
conversation during which Henry shares
that he also tried to do some Drilling
in the past but he was never as
successful as Daniel he reveals that he
got into some trouble which made him
serve the prison for some time
afterwards Daniel puts his son to bed
and steps outside to continue chatting
with his brother this time he asks the
real motive why Henry showed up in
response the latter asserts that he
neither wants money nor favors he just
wants to work with him the two then
spend the evening drinking and sharing
their past although Daniel hides many
details from him on the other hand HW
believes that his father will now
prioritize his brother over him which
makes him feel jealous as a result he
sets fire to their house intending to
kill Henry in his sleep however his plan
fails as both Henry and Daniel wake up
in time and frantically begin to put out
the fire seeing this the boy tries to
run away but Daniel brings him back the
following day Daniel takes HW on a train
pretending that they're going for a trip
together but in reality he is sending
the boy to a special boarding school as
the train is about to depart Daniel
excuses himself and gets off the train
leaving the kid alone in the next scene
Daniel and Henry have a meeting with
Standard Oil Representatives who wish to
buy out Daniel's entire business as well
as his land they can even offer him good
money suggesting that he can spend the
rest of his life with his son however
Daniel feels insulted by this and turns
down the offer before storming off in
the midst of his work he often asks his
men about his son and how well he is
adapting to City Life as time passes by
Daniel strikes a deal with Union oil to
build a pipeline to the California coast
however there arises a problem the last
bit of land belonging to William doesn't
belong to them in an attempt to resolve
the issue Daniel visits his house but
the latter has apparently gone on a
holiday afterwards Daniel and Henry
worked together to Market a passage for
the pipeline by placing metal stakes in
specific locations around the land after
several hours of work the brothers swim
in the ocean before relaxing on the
beach during this time Daniel recalls
some stories from their past but Henry
fails to recognize a local joke which
raises his suspicions So Daniel
confronts him while they are camping in
the forest he holds him at gunpoint and
demands to know why he's here Henry
finally admits that he is just an
impostor and that he met the real Henry
in King City they worked together
together on the same farm and quickly
became FRS according to him the real
Henry wanted to visit his brother but he
didn't have enough money to travel years
later he was diagnosed with tuberculosis
which eventually took his life the
impostor then learned all the details of
Henry's Life by reading his personal
Journal after knowing everything he
could he impersonated Henry in hopes
that Daniel would give him a job
although the impostor promises to leave
and never return an enraged Daniel guns
him down and buries his body in the
ground after this he reads his brother's
diary and weeps the next morning Daniel
is awakened by William who seems to be
aware of the sin he committed the
previous night the old man then asks him
to publicly repent and undergo baptism
in Eli's church because that's the only
way he will permit Daniel to build the
pipeline across his land left with no
other choice Daniel accepts his
condition for the sake of his project
William then takes him to the church
where Eli as a part of his baptism
humiliates him and forces him into
confessing that he abandoned his son he
also declares to the congregation that
Daniel will be making a large donation
to the church which the ladder can't
refuse from that point onwards the
construction of the pipeline commences
without any issue apart from this Daniel
also brings HW back to him and
apologizes for abandoning him a teacher
has also come with the boy so that he
can continue learning sign language that
afternoon Daniel takes his son to a
restaurant where they come across the
same representatives from Standard Oil
Daniel can't resist boasting about his
huge deal with Union oil on the other
hand Eli leaves the place to do his
missionary work the scene then fast
forwards to 1927 and HW who is now an
adult Mary's Mary we also see Daniel who
has become a very wealthy man living in
a huge mansion with several servants
however living alone has made him
alcoholic and depressed one evening HW
along with his interpreter pays Daniel a
visit to have a private conversation he
starts by saying he loves him very much
but he misses working in the field as a
result he has decided that he and Mary
will be relocating to Mexico in order to
establish his own drilling company
Daniel is infuriated to hear this and
claims that this will only make them
competitors in a drunken rage he then
mocks hws deafness and even spills the
truth he's not his son but an orphan
whom he used to make his business good
this Revelation leaves HW heartbroken so
he walks away after a asserting that
he's glad there's no relation between
them depressed and inebriated Daniel
then falls asleep in his bowling alley
on the following day he is woken up by
Eli who is now a radio preacher as they
start conversing Eli continuously
reminds him that they are family-in-law
which provokes Daniel's anger Eli also
tells him about William's recent death
and that the property rights are now
owned by William's grandson since his
grandson is the church member Eli offers
to become a mediator and sell Daniel the
property the latter agrees on the
condition that Eli acknowledges himself
as a false prophet and deny God's
existence when Daniel offers him
$100,000 Eli agrees and repeats the
statement just like he made him admit
his sin in the church earlier after
doing this Daniel coldly reveals that
the property is now worthless because
his neighboring Wells have already
drained the same oil reservoir I drink
your milkshake this Revelation breaks
Eli lie down in tears making him confess
that he lost all of his money in the
1929 stock market crash and is strayed
morally he pleads with Daniel for help
but the latter doesn't feel pity for him
he instead begins to taunt him by
proclaiming that Paul is the real chosen
one who is now a successful businessman
when Eli implores him to stop Daniel
tosses him into the bowling alley and
launches several bowling balls at him
although Eli evades the balls a drunk
Daniel chases him and knocks him down
with a in pin in a merciless attack
Daniel strikes him on the head multiple
times until he passes away hearing the
commotion a servant appears to check and
Daniel announces that he's finished